I'm going to start with the most
important one probably right up front
um and I want to make sure you're seated
for this you are uh so who wins in a
fight uh John Wick or Tyler Rick
that's like the greatest question of all
time
because I I mean that's tough
because I was uh you know part I'm
partial to the character of Tyler Rick
and
take away all right I'm going to take
away John Wick's bulletproof suit and
I'm going to give it to Tyler Rick the
dudes a bit you can dude's a badass so
there's no there's no debate there's no
you don't I mean you know what I mean
like if you weren't the director you you
know okay so you want me to just put
just be like a fan remove myself like
you know like like looking at it from
like action looking at it from
everything being honest do you think
Tyler has this in the bag no like no one
had John Wick is a is a verb now like
he's like to John Wickson like it's a
thing he that's a he's a legend
even he's a legend on screen in his own
movies and yet he's a legend now as a
like a action icon so no that dude
doesn't go down without a fight but the
fourth movie proves he can go down and
we've proven that our guy can be killed
and brought back from the dead so you
gotta give it to Tyler Rick a long
hard-fought battle to be sure but I
think you gotta go with Tyler Rick
Okay I accept that I think that if I
asked Chad he would probably say Wick of
course I mean of course he would and he
probably wouldn't even be a long heart
if he's like no I'm Wick in five you
know five seconds but
I'm just trying to imagine the two of
you uh uh craft how each of you would uh
craft that action set piece and you know
what I mean yeah it would be why it
would be wildly different and but I
think I mean hopefully entertaining both
no matter how you cracked it because
those two guys in a scene together would
be
insane let's be honest I I absolutely
agree um do you view obviously you now
made extraction two and I know that
Netflix is already thinking about a
third one because the first one was one
of the most successful films in Netflix
history and the fact that the sequel is
good you know there's no there's no way
they don't want a third so my question
is do you view the extraction series
it's like your John Wick series the way
God made for John Wicks
um you know I
and it's too early to tell truthfully
you know because the I think
the as they did with the WIC movies I
think you kind of have to wait and see
how the audience reacts like just
because the first movie was successful
doesn't mean the second one's gonna you
know be more so that's not a given right
like you hope you hope and it's tracking
well but there's who knows like
something else we had a pandemic happen
the first time that helped us out
something else could happen that Mill
doesn't help us out so you never know
um the appetite is strong for a you know
continuation of Tyler Rick and his
journeys for sure and that's something I
would love to see and you know be a part
of but it's it's too early to tell and I
I try not to look that far in advance
you know what is it like going from man
will I ever get to direct a movie to
people offering you projects and wanting
to meet with you two direct movies it's
it's amazing it's flattering to for
people to want to want to work with me
to direct a movie is super flattering
because and I it's funny you say like uh
well asking the question well anybody
ever hire me I I knew someday they would
and if they didn't I do it myself and
I'd make a movie like I knew that was
gonna happen however to be given the
opportunity alike extraction with you
know to work with Netflix Chris
Hemsworth the Russo brothers and like
you know
um that is a dream come true that I
never expected I was expecting that like
here here's you know here's a million
dollars go make a fun movie and we'll
see what you can do
um and I was fully expecting that but
yeah to have this opportunity never
would have expected it so now to have
done that and not falling flat on my
face which was a you know welcome relief
and then have other people say oh like
um maybe you want to do this movie or
how about this TV TV show it's very
flattering and it's a you know it's a
lot to um to process but it very
flattering and I hopefully can can keep
doing things
um that people enjoy watching now that
you are coming into the home stretch
you're going to promote this movie I
know you're already thinking about what
will I do next so I usually save this to
the end but I'm just going to ask it now
do you know what you're going to do next
uh yes at the I am where I'm doing a TV
show for Apple at the end of the year up
in uh Canada to call it the Last
Frontier it's uh the John bochen Camp uh
wrote it and is show running it and I'm
gonna direct the pilot and the second
third episode and then executive produce
for the series it's the one with Jason
Clark yes Jason Clark starring as yeah
as the the lead and it's it's a pretty
fun story just a propulsive and you know
thrilling and I just I think it's going
to be a fun challenge because I haven't
really done anything in the TV space and
I love the idea of long-form
Storytelling and setting up this world
that then other people can come in and
Riff on and hopefully improve and
hopefully the series goes on and on and
on is it one of these things where you
are already thinking to yourself like
because obviously you've done a lot of
you you know how to do action so where
are you already thinking about like what
am I going to do in the TV space with
action or is it you know what I mean
like how are you going to balance that
sensibility of crafting an incredible
action set piece versus hopefully you
understand what I was just saying I know
what you're talking about because you
get you know you're talking about
realities here which is there's less
usually
less time and less money crafting a TV
show than there is a feature right we
had the time we're going to have to do
like the pilot episode which has a bunch
of crazy stuff is going to be like a
quarter of what we had for extraction so
part of it is going to be
shifting my you know not shifting Styles
because it Excellence is something that
I want to strive for no matter what I'm
doing but I am going to have to you know
be present in the reality of there's
less time less money so you got to
figure out a way to do something
exciting with less time and less money
so I think that's an interesting
challenge because oftentimes
creativity comes from boundaries you
know um you can have when you have
anything and everything you need
sometimes your your mind can just run
too free and it gets spread too thin
sometimes when it's like all right this
you're in a you're in a shoe box figure
something out and you go all right well
now your focus is so much sharper so I
think that's going to be a fun challenge
you know who knows we'll see I'm I'm
looking forward to it though it's a
really exciting script and I'm really
looking forward to diving into it yeah
uh I will say I'm very impressed with
Apple TV and the stuff that they've been
making it's all very high quality it
looks great and um they spend money like
it they do really good yeah no I think
it's great they're very supportive so I
hear again I have limited experience
I've been talking with the line
producers and and the producers over
there but we haven't shot anything yet
from what I hear or other folks is
they're very supportive of the artists
yeah jumping into why I get to talk to
you
um so a while ago when I was talking to
Joe he teased that extraction 2 could be
a prequel it could be a sequel he was
always getting cagey with the answer so
how close did it come to being a pre
equal rather than a sequel I mean it we
talked about it like it was I think that
was mostly Joe B and kg because he's a
smart businessman you don't want to give
too much away too early
um and it's good to lead people off the
scent right and say oh we're gonna do a
prequel look over there while we figure
out the sequel
um because I don't think you can leave a
character
um or leave an audience
with that ending and then not go figure
out like what happened explain because
that's the question everyone's like what
how what how who when what was that how
did that happen and so to we have to
answer that question so it was never
seriously a prequel um just because it
always felt like moving forward for
Tyler rake was going to be more powerful
because if we go backwards now you're
kind of dealing with you're rehashing
the like similar thing of like his past
right because it's hard to get more
emotionally
um fraught and higher Stakes than your
son dying with cancer like leukemia
right so to go back to that that then
you'd kind of be retreading similar
ground at knowing where you're gonna
peek emotionally so we figured forward
is the best way you know have him still
living with that guilt but then
introduce some new emotional stakes and
new characters that he has to deal with
he thought that would probably be a
little bit more
um enjoyable for the audience and just
better for the character moving forward
I think I noticed a certain Cameo from
you in the movie
um as a Gravedigger
um how would you die yeah how did you
how how did you decide that was going to
be my Cameo basically I was so busy with
everything else that I just ran out of
time like you know there were places
where I was like oh I could do that like
not too busy I could do that no it's too
much this was actually an additional
scene that we had written while we were
we cut the movie together while we were
you know working and we were like oh we
need some more information some more
backstory on these villains
let's you know let's do this scene and
that was actually a character that not
not for me to play but that I kind of
came up with like well what if they're
you know while they're they're walking
you just see this you know this this
ditch being dugged and like we just walk
right up to it and we're like huh and
then you know the guy gets off and falls
in the ditch and it's just all kind of
kind of like very gangster very like um
you know mafia-esque and so I was like
well that's a pretty simple part hard to
screw that one up I'll I'll just jump in
the ditch and dig it now I tried because
I mean you got me uh you caught me there
I tried we I put a wig on I had like uh
Chris's guys put a put a wig on me we
dyed my beard or at least put some some
more gray in it
um but you still got me so I didn't I
didn't do that good of a job of hiding
my identity I also have a good eye for
movies it's it's a you know
um so um jumping into the way you and
Joe talked about how you wanted this
sequel to be in terms of the story I'm
so curious because one of the things
about the first film is it has these
incredible action set pieces obviously
that is going to be the Mantra going
forward with extraction movies
incredible action set pieces so how is
it before Joe started writing how much
are you guys talking about you thinking
I would love like a prison sequence or I
would love to do this and then Joe is
writing these sequences and how much is
it show saying this is my idea and then
what do you you know what I mean like
how are you figuring out where the
action is going to go because obviously
that's the big hook of these movies yeah
it's a little bit of both and a lot of
the second one meaning Joe is
the guy has a creative mind and he knows
an action set piece like very few like
his structurally like the you know the
we had a 30 page outline in a couple
weeks it was just like bam all right
this is I think what would be a great
journey for them now we talked about
while we were on I think the first movie
or towards the end the first inkling of
a second movie was what if Tyler Rick
was you know in a prison and and we had
to fight his way out or had to get in
and get out of a prison and rescue
someone in a Warner and that was a
conversation that we had so that was
like that was the first thing about the
second movie that was talked about and
it stayed in there which is great and I
think it worked so that was the seed
that was planted and then from there you
know we wanted to do something
um because the other movie was very much
nitty-gritty and dirty and we're like if
we're gonna go to a prison which is very
similar in that field we need to kind of
contrast that with a little more I don't
want to say um you know highbrow but
like um just a cleaner sparklier look so
we went we found like a you know a big
city which was in Vienna which across
the river to the more modern side
and found this high rise we're like okay
shiny glass that's very different than
the first movie because
the challenge of a sequel is how do you
make the movie feel very similar so
people get what they love but how do you
make it very different in the look and
the feel but not so much that you turn
off the fan base so we wanted you know
the first movie had these a lot of
orange and you know warm tones because
of where we were we wanted it to feel
hot and it was we shot in India in
Thailand it was very hot and so now
we're in Eastern Europe where it's very
cold like in the winter time so there's
more blues and Grays and we tried to
lean into that so the glass and concrete
you know is just a very
um great contrast visually and tonally
from the first movie and you know the DP
Greg baldy and I and the production
designer Phil Ivey leaned heavily into
that and it was yeah it was always
something we searched for it was
contrast from the first movie and I
think we found it I'm just already
thinking about extraction three and I'm
just envisioning you guys in Tokyo so
what do I need to like have you guys go
to Tokyo to make extraction three there
because the visuals there are so
different and so amazing I don't know if
you've been there that I'm just
imagining Tyler and you guys filming
action there and I'm already excited
yeah that are I mean just putting Tyler
in a place like that seems like putting
a bull in a china shop I love it this
that yeah send me an email we'll we'll
pass it down the we'll pass it down the
line we'll get it we'll get it in the on
the list I mean there's a long list of
places that we could possibly go let's
put I'm sure Tokyo is already there
let's let's throw it in there move it to
the top how about that yeah I'm I'm just
I've been lucky enough to go there and
it's like a different world you know it
just looks so anyway I'm just I'm just
pitching and I shouldn't be doing that
um hey but this is actually there's I
love it because fan reactions and fan
ideas
spark creativity like there's no I I
would I welcome ideas because truthfully
some of the ideas for Action like aren't
coming out of my brain they're coming
like suggestions people like write a
comment sometimes being funny sometimes
being like you know facetious and I go
wait a second hold on now if I take that
the seat there is they're trying to be
like sarcastic but that could be
brilliant you know like
and I I did that like with a number of
different action pieces where like
someone says haha where he should do
this sarcastically and I'm like well
guess what he's gonna do that
so so that all of those suggestions I
take them to heart and doesn't mean you
know that we are definitely going to go
there but that idea I welcome the man
now you don't say shouldn't I love it no
no I'm saying for going to Asia for the
third one makes a whole lot of sense
because it's just it would look and feel
radically different than the ones you've
done before love it hey noted you heard
it here first folks yeah exactly we end
up if you end up in Asia you know who to
think no uh no that'll be all you guys
so what one of the things about
extraction 2 is some of the set pieces
are especially the train sequence
they're they're I was going to curse
they are crazy and I think a lot of
people are not going to realize when
they're watching it how much was done
practically and how much was done like
how it was done practically and you'll
think oh that was a computer I mean like
and you can tell when you're watching it
like there's obviously CGI enhancements
but it's not like but structurally
there's a so much practically so talk a
little bit about if you don't mind that
what what you actually did this is not
fake you actually did crazy [__]
that's the quote that's that the title
of the article that is we actually did
crazy [__] on extraction too uh but we
wouldn't be the first action franchise
to do crazy things however in the DNA of
extraction is definitely to do as much
practically as possible so with the
train sequence we fully embraced it we
were on a real train out in the you know
nether regions of the Prague Czech
Republic like we were I think it was
North or Northeast and closer to Germany
and we
um and don't quote my geography that's
me early in the morning and we're we're
away from Prague out in the mountains it
was amazing and cold and beautiful so on
a real train the helicopters are real
you know we had real
stunt performers and you know para
jumpers and uh I think we had like Army
Rangers like one of our performers
coming out of the Choppers Army Rangers
so this it's about as real as it gets
and the the only CG that we did was
background
um
yeah back plates which was because of
the you know the the
power plant where we got onto the train
was not in the same location as where we
were filming the train so just they just
didn't exist in the same spot so we had
to then recreate that power plant behind
them but everything like you know the
snowing and the the helicopter flying in
and landing on the train that was all
practical that was real and I don't know
if you've walked under a helicopter as
it's Landing but there is the the wind
the force it takes to keep the
helicopter off the ground is very it's
that's powerful winds so to walk under
that holding a camera which I was doing
to get that shot was shockingly
difficult
um and I the first the first attempt and
this who knows if they'll release this
behind the scenes but the first attempt
blew me off the train and luckily I was
tethered in they had it we had we call a
dog leash like a a cable that ran along
the edge of the train that was hooked to
just in case something like that
happened and it did like it was so so
much force that I was prepared for but
not prepared for it blew me off to the
side and I like you know Cameron one
hand holding onto the train with the
other and it almost fell off the train
but for that safety leash so
what we were doing was very dangerous it
was very very real and the tank that's
in the movie you know I think it was the
third of five because the more we did it
the better our you know pilot Fred North
got at Landing the helicopter and it
became too perfect when we watched it we
got back and we watched it we're like it
looks fake because he lands it and it's
almost like it sticks to the train it
was so per just so perfect the guys get
off and he takes off we're like it looks
fake it looks like we you know it's all
on a blue screen and we dropped it down
on the crane and just didn't move and it
just takes off so we we went with the
take where there was a kind of a
crosswind that he was fighting and you
can see his like the concentration in
his eyes and it's bouncing a little bit
on the train and the guy's hopping off
is a little more whoa but we use that
take because it was more real and we
were kind of cognizant of people's
expectations that it would be fake and
so we wanted to try as hard as possible
to say nah this is real and so we used
the one that was a little bit rougher of
a landing what is it like behind the
scenes on a sequence like that in terms
of the safety precautions to make sure
God forbid something does go wrong that
because you're in the middle of nowhere
like what do you do you know like how
much how much are you figuring out like
is it months in advance like what
happens God forbid something goes wrong
very much so that that sequence we
started the movie with those seven days
so we we were prepping you know all the
other bits of the movie were important
but they were kind of like they're down
a little further we're focusing on the
train we had five uh PJs which was like
para jumpers like para rescue from the
air force that were with us and we
brought them in specifically for that
reason because if something happened you
know Medics are great but these guys
have been through combat they've seen
some pretty you know unfortunately some
pretty gnarly stuff so something happens
they would be the ones we would want to
turn to with life lighting somebody out
like having to direct all of um you know
the the rescue effort so to speak so we
had five PJs two of which were you know
on the train but not involved in the
sequence
um a couple of which were actually
getting out of the helicopter
but mostly they were on the ground just
like talking to the helicopter
communicating with the train conductor
and with our ads and just keeping an eye
on everything they had the you know the
the uh Life Flight helicopter up and
running and ready to go it was just this
huge effort
in case something went wrong because we
worked we're out in the middle of
nowhere the closest hospital was you
know probably an hour away so it was all
very well planned very well thought out
we actually the entire crew went out
there weeks in advance to rehearse
leading up to the first day of shooting
because
those sequences involve so many
different departments it's not just okay
stunts and actors and a camera go for it
there's you know grip and electric are
doing their thing you got all of the
different lenses you got to carry with
you and focus pullers we had a a caravan
like the the stuff that went into the
planning this wasn't saying our ad
Department was amazing because you had
the train that was on camera
and you had you know the engine and I
think there were like two cars but then
you had two more cars that housed all of
our you know film gear all of our extra
people like the you know the hair makeup
costume that they had to be involved we
had props armors stunts
people that because when we leave the
station it's miles away and we can't get
back for something that we need not
effectively so we carried it all with us
so we had to plan you know which way the
camera was looking at what time during
what day because overnight they'd have
to reconfigure those trains it's not
like a you know a car in a parking lot
we're like okay we're gonna look this
way now just unhook the trailer and re
you got to take it all the way back to
the station like you know 15 20 miles
away overnight you got people that
moving around the yard you're gonna move
the tracks move it forward move the
tracks again like reconfiguring these
cars every night depending on what we
were shooting what day it was a like
planning and techno uh technical miracle
that this team pulled off and it went
without a hitch that's why we we started
with it because we were so focused on
that like I said three weeks of
rehearsal with everyone there beforehand
and then we started rolling cameras so
that we would be all very well a
well-oiled machine so to speak and we
had our we had our goal we had it we had
rehearsed it and we just went right into
it and filmed for seven days without a
hitch and it was I think one of the most
it was it was the most impressive and
wild sequence I've ever been a part of
because
it's not that the set was necessarily
bigger than like a Marvel movie or or
something like that but it was a real
train moving at high speeds with all of
our casts and Talent on it in it around
it helicopters like the front when when
we're over you know Tyler Rick's
shoulder and he's shooting down that
helicopter at the front of the train
no you're not crashing a real helicopter
because we love Fred North that's a take
a CG takeover but the lead but the lead
up to that
is Fred North Flying sideways at 40
miles an hour
10 feet away from Chris Hemsworth like
our lead actor
if something goes south it goes really
South really fast and it's just
catastrophic but we had this again the
rehearsal process was
so detailed and our stunt team was and
safety team were so great it just were
out there just over and over again like
calculating the exact to the millisecond
of how long we had between you know the
power lines and the trees all right this
is how much time you have and if
something you know if if this then that
if this then that and there's so many
contingencies and anyways it was an
amazing feat of filmmaking and I'm super
proud of every single person that was a
part of it and yeah I don't know if
we'll ever be part of something like
that again yeah I don't um I'm so
impressed that Chris did that sequence
because you couldn't pay me enough money
to stand 10 feet from a helicopter or
like that close no chance yeah it was
it's wild it's it's and again you know
you see it in the movie and you're like
oh that's wild but you when you're there
in person it's a it's a such a different
energy and like we've tried to capture
that as best we could with getting the
camera because there were times when
when I would walk past it I could reach
out and high five Fred if he wasn't so
concentrated on Landing in the
helicopter and I wasn't so concentrated
I'm not falling off the train and
photographing it so that people could
enjoy it it was it was wild and super
intense hopefully people you know have
some sort of
um pucker Factor if you will in that
sequence where they just go oh yeah I I
think you definitely should release
behind the scenes footage to show people
how real that was because I think people
are going to watch it and really not
understand because it's so crazy you
know but I want to switch to another
sequence which is the present okay let's
do it so how long did you actually film
to do the prison sequence well the
prison sequence
um you know for in my mind comprises a
couple different parts and it was
actually a couple different locations so
once you Tyler Rick goes into that
prison and pulls the family out there's
a little scene in the cell and it was
kind of a couple different locations one
was actually where they shot Mission
Impossible five I think it was when um
it was either four or five when when uh
when Tom Cruise goes in to pull the Yuri
that like the Russian uh the Russian guy
out of prison we filmed in that same
location which I didn't even know until
I re-watched that mission impossible and
was like wait I know those doors uh
anyway so we shot there that was where
the corridors were that was where we you
know got the family out and we started
the the first part of the sequence where
he's running up and down stairs and he's
fighting guys in his room and then when
he goes down and into the the darkness
into the tunnels that lead up to the
coal shoots that was in one of our
hidden you know edits we moved locations
went many many miles away to another
location which used to be like a a
storage facility for grain uh during you
know World War II and so they had this
crazy Courtyard which ended up being the
courtyard portion of the the prison
and the underground tunnel system was
amazing and so we really wanted to take
advantage of that
and so that's part of the my process
with scouting you find these places that
might work and then you see like oh
that's really cool let's add this or
find a way to work this in and so we did
and actually the area where the furnace
is was behind this bricked up wall and
there was a pipe going through it and
there's enough room for me to fit my
head through so when we were scouting I
had my flashlight and it was like you
know the tunnels were cool but then I
shined through there and I was like whoa
like it keeps going guys I was like hey
and then I asked the locations folks
like how
tied to this wall are the owners of this
building and they're like I'll ask and
they're like no this they put it up for
whatever reason I was like great let's
take it down so we smashed down a wall
opened up this whole space I don't know
when the last time that was used or even
had humans in it
um so anyway that I love that side of
filmmaking like just discovering new
things opportunities to see places you
never would in real life and so anyway
we so we combined those two locations
and so from the time that the water
starts to the time that they exit and
start the car chase that prison park I
think took us it was like five or six
days that's crazy I would have figured
it would have taken more time but maybe
it's because you do extensive rehearsals
well extensive rehearsals and it's like
you have to
um you know there's a certain Pace you
have to get with the with the stitches
right so you look at it broken down kind
of like a shot list and you're like all
right for example and we're on the first
movie we averaged between three and five
you know stitches or pieces that we put
together per day
and with this one it was like twice as
long so we're like well we did have a
little bit longer to shoot I think all
in with the Train the car chase the um
the prison I think we had 27 days or
something like that which is the time it
takes if some people could film an
entire movie in that time or maybe two
you know like we'll be shooting like two
TV shows two two episodes for this last
frontier pilot in that time so we had
you know to shoot one sequence but it
was that ambitious so
we just and part of the thing that you
you actually when you think about it it
makes sense that is a little I love it
about the Wonder is once you
rehearse it and design it and get it how
you like it once you've got it and it
works with the next piece you move on
whereas you know if you're traditionally
covering something like you look at it
One Direction you have you know you're
there for whatever like a couple hours a
day now that's great now you got to turn
around and get the other side so that
you have the other coverage but with the
wonder you're covering all of it it's
all in one shot and so once you have
that piece you don't go back to it so
you just keep moving and so it does some
in some ways allow you to move a little
faster
because you don't have to go back and
recover things and get the inserts it's
all in one so yeah it was about about
six days for that and the prison
Courtyard where all that you know most
of the martial arts action stuff
happened the crazy going from you know
gun to knife to hand to hand and they
get we do snoring Cam and all this crazy
stuff that was only three nights I think
we did three three nights there yeah
that sequence is again it's another
[__] it's another crazy one um what one
of the things I'm curious about though
so what I love about the prison thing is
um it gets pretty brutal towards the end
when uh when Chris is fighting I don't
want to do spoilers here but it gets
pretty brutal how much is that Joe in
the script saying some of these things
and how much is it you on set saying oh
we're gonna do this and then we're gonna
do this it's a little bit of a third
thing which is the the script inspires
me to talk with the the stunt team and
then we hire the best people in the
business and let them do their thing and
I kind of curate as it were so I I say
all right here here's what
you know I want here in the script it
goes from here to here to here and maybe
Joe wrote something and then we talk
about it's like how how tied to certain
things are you like do you really want
this to happen and he'd be like hey as
long as it you know the character beat
happens as long as I get this moment it
can be anything and we go great so then
I go all right guys this is what I'm
thinking for this
um but sometimes sometimes they'll be
very specific
but most of the time I just try to
convey a feeling to them and I actually
that bit where you know he's surrounded
and he starts with the rifle and anyway
he goes through all the different
weapons I I pulled up a National
Geographic special where is a lion like
a single lion surrounded by a bunch of
hyenas and it's like a three or four
minute clip of this lion fighting for
his life on the Savannah with a bunch of
hyenas attacking him and you know and I
would pause it places and said like see
that look in that Lion's eye
that's what I want from Tyler Rick like
that's how we should feel right now and
you know it's like oh okay he's like how
we get there what you the you know the
martial arts moves we use to arrive here
I'm not necessarily as concerned about
because you guys are the best
um but this is the feeling I want and
you watch like when he when he attacks
one there's three of them coming from
behind and they're like they're you know
going for his legs and like he turns
around so I want him to be the lion and
all these prisoners to be the hyenas so
that was my direction and you know they
went out and did an amazing job and
they'll bring it they'll shoot the viz
you know stunt viz they'll bring it to
me and I'll look at it a lot of it for
timing especially in a Warner because
you're like
you know okay you gotta watch it with
the sense of an audience member where if
you start to go like you start to tune
out or you start to like reach for your
phone or whatever it is you go haha it's
too long we need to you know adjust this
adjust that or change the direction
something has to happen here it's too
much kicking and punching we need a
moment
um and that was actually where it came
because originally it was just Tyler
Rick working his way through the you
know the
the prison yard to get to the family
and then when we started looking at the
choreography it was like
it started feeling like I've seen most
of these things before like you know oh
boy did it so great they did it in like
the protector like it was a lot of one
guy versus a lot of people how do we
complicate this for Tyler Rick and I was
like hmm what if we split the family up
and now he's got to fight his way
through with the mom so now that lion is
protecting you know the Cub or something
you know and so then immediately the
stakes went from you know here oh oh no
Tyler's in trouble to hear because it's
Tyler and this you know innocent woman
he's trying to protect so little things
like that is what as a director I'm
trying to bring
um and then with the with the with the
fight stuff you know I'll I'll say I
want to end with an exclamation point
and it's like how about and I might
suggest how about we smack the dude's
head with a weight and they'll be like
love it yeah little things little things
like that like it could be specific and
sometimes my suggestions make it
sometimes they don't but it's really I
put it to the group to the sun team
because they are that's what they do
that's how they live and I was fortunate
enough to on a lot of the films that I
did where I would be entrusted with
those things and so to I don't want to
micromanage my team I want them to have
the freedom and ownership of the fight
stuff I will because I'm overseeing the
whole thing I'll go in and tweak things
here and there but it's a combination of
all three Joe writes the script we find
those character moments I turn the stunt
team loose with a feeling that I want to
achieve and then I go in and kind of
curate the moves that I like that flow
best for my sensibilities so one of the
things that I really respond to with
Chris in the extraction films and also
Chris in general is that he's willing to
take a punch he's willing to get shot
he's willing to make it that he's not a
superhero in these movies like he takes
damage and there are some action stars
that don't like to be seen getting beat
up on screen I'm not going to mention
any name
there are some and if you watch the
movies you'll see which ones they are so
can you sort of talk about because I
think that adds a lot to the movie that
Chris is willing to take that punch well
part of part of what yeah I totally
agree and I think that's one thing that
makes Tyler Reich so great and
a lot of that for me comes from
loving Jackie Chan movies so much
growing up and what I think he did that
separated him from the Bruce Lee's and
Jet Li's is
he wasn't the martial arts expert who
it was now the the viewing pleasure was
kind of um
voyeuristic in that or or um you know
you're living out your fantasies of
being Untouchable and you were how is he
going to dismantle these people like
Steven Seagal he doesn't get touched how
is he going to dismantle all these
people and that's part of the fun
what made Jackie Chan so exciting was he
always put people who whether they were
actually in real life or not but like
better Fighters around him and he would
have his character get beaten up
so that he had now that it made the the
next time they meet or how is he going
to get out of that situation so much
more dramatically interesting because
you're you're worried for his safety
it's not sit back you know pop the
popcorn and be like oh man I can't wait
to see him be I know he's going to beat
him all up how is he going to do it it's
like oh is he going to survive this I
don't know if Jackie's gonna make it so
you know Chris is great in that we when
we talked about it he was very much a
fan of being I mean he borders in this
movie he borders on superhero status
because he does some pretty incredible
things however we wanted to make sure
that he wasn't just floating through it
and not getting injured we wanted him to
pay for you know to make sacrifices
because you know the the greater the
struggle the more glorious the Triumph
so we wanted to make him earn it and
that was you know in the in the
courtyard when he gets smacked in the
back of the head and he kind of go it
just falls down we're kind of like oh no
is he gonna make it
um and anyway I think it's really
refreshing working with an actor who is
is willing to for the character he
separates his ego from the character
that he's playing and is saying like
that's not me this character the best
thing for this movie and this character
is to take punishment so that when I
Prevail everyone feels that victory that
much more I definitely want to talk
about editing real quick
um did you have what did you learn in
the editing room how did the film change
if you will based on friends and family
screenings test screenings in ways you
didn't expect oh man I mean this this
movie had all kinds of iterations uh it
originally
on paper it was scripted as in it read
great it was scripted as it starts with
the winner
and then we go through that crazy
sequence and then we stop flashback to
how Rick came to survive and then keep
going with the story
and so we put it together that way and
it was you know it was it was cool to
start with the Warner it's just the
because it was it's so epic
you get a little lost in tracking the
why and the who because if you haven't
met like there's new characters he's
saving this woman that you had who's
speaking Georgian I don't know who this
is and he's two kids who is this and so
because it goes on so long like if that
was a three minute sequence you could do
that it's a 21 minute and seven second
sequence it was much harder to do that
because you just people were just
guessing longer than we wanted them to
so then we're like okay and that's what
I love about you know what what the
Russo's do really well is it's the adage
of the best idea wins so that was how it
was scripted and many times a lot of you
know producers or Studios would be like
that's how our writers even that's how
it's scripted that's what I want make it
that way and but we tried something
different we had one of our editors was
like Hey what if we try it linearly so
that we get to know who these people are
we answer the question of how he
survived right up front because that's
what people want to know
and then we started watching it linearly
and we're like you know what it actually
is stronger this way it's a slow burn
like it builds and there's not it's
crazy there's not an and traditional
action sequence in the first 23 minutes
like you have to wait where we're making
you know we're making you wait and earn
it
but then when it starts it doesn't stop
like it goes all the way to the end
you're just like whoa that was crazy so
that was a huge change that we weren't
necessarily expecting but I love that
that's part of the editing process to me
is discovering magic in the room
something that you never would have
considered you never would have tried
and there were you know there was a lot
of other side stories that kind of got
trimmed or we had to you know kind of go
back in and re uh invigorate some of the
connection between rake and the the
family there was some
there was a lot of additional things
that came in during the editing process
that we just had some really great
editors working on it and you know some
awesome Minds very collaborative and you
know arrived at what we all felt was the
best version of the film yeah I got to
tell you as a fan um I don't think it
would have worked starting with the
action set piece because of exactly what
you said which is who are these people
like why do I care you know like all of
that stuff
um so did you did you end up with a lot
of deleted scenes or is it just little
bits of scene no it's more it's more a
rearranging of this you know the the
scenes that were there and it actually
amazingly it worked pretty well now we
we added a few scenes we deleted a few
but no we didn't you know we trimmed a
lot like I think the movie like you know
the original assembly it was like two
and a half hours long or something so we
you know we trimmed out like half an
hour of footage which most movies you
know they're long and then you trim them
down to the most palatable version but
yeah we didn't there's not a lot of
scenes that ended up on The Cutting Room
floor I mean there's sections that we
had to to pull but it was more
tightening what was there rearranging
what was there and then bolstering some
of the story threads that we wanted to
really pay off on so you get to do a
training montage with Chris you know
recovering from his thing from the
injuries to get ready to go how much are
you looking at Rocky and every other
training montage and being like what am
I going to do for mine well you
you can't not do a montage and not think
of Rocky they they basically made the
Montage cool they made it what it is I
mean they kind of redefined or defined
the Montage so definitely thinking of
that but trying to and actually my
biggest fear was that we'd end up making
a center fit workout video for that for
Chris uh because he's got so many so
many great references of great workouts
that he does like that's part of his
Persona is his physical fitness and he
has an app and he's got his website like
that's what he does
so it was kind of like oh man how do we
how are we gonna have you train that
doesn't look like it's a you know a plug
for Center fit so we we ended up on and
hopefully my dad will enjoy it we ended
up on you know a lot of physical
activities that were
um
goal oriented but also Fitness related
meaning you know things that uh you know
where like the deadlift exercise came
from so you could lift heavier things so
he's lifting rocks rather than like a
bar and dead lifting he's take and we
progressively made him like you know
start smaller and then like bigger and
bigger Bolder so that by the end he's
got this big you know 300 pound Boulder
he's picking up doing like a big dead
lift and dropping it but he's building
something like he's building a wall to
improve the cabin and he's rather than
just you know hitting a tire with a
sledgehammer which you know works the so
many muscles he's got a an ax and he's
cutting wood because it's cold and he's
gotta you know feed the fire or he's you
know doing pull-ups but from rope
because the rope that you know was down
at the dock by the lake we tried to
incorporate things that would be in his
environment
uh with activities that would be
functional and yet somewhat interesting
to watch and of course we were trying
not to rip off too much of uh the rocky
franchise